he was hoping
they'd like him for who he was
just jimmy not because he sold
10 billion records or not because he was
the best guitar player in the world you
know
none of that or that he wrote phenomenal
phenomenal songs
he wanted them to like just jimmy
i mean and i'm just i'm not saying this
doesn't going on that this is in a
not a need based situation that it is
it is a need-based situation but he was
hoping for a higher need meaning you
really were
you loved his personality he loved his
humor you loved his way
of being you loved his love you know
whatever
but not just because his his name is
jimmy and
maybe he wanted a deeper connection says
it in a simple way he wanted
you know did he ever have a long-term
girlfriend or anything like that i don't
know
an assortment yeah an assortment
never someone that he could
settle down with and have children with
and maybe that's what he was looking for
and he found something
much more shallower with all these young
teeny boppers
bouncing through his hotel room every
night exactly exactly
exactly i i wish i could empathize with
with his problem but i can't imagine
putting myself in his shoes
so i don't know but if the
15 were lined up each day
after a year or two you got to select
one or two
or three you know yeah you got you know
and they're they're here because they
hear you're a billionaire
you're a billionaire you're just he's a
rich guy oh we
we'll have it we'll take some time with
him or he's rich and he does
this or that whatever the thing is you
know after a while you'd go
uh well i like the sex but
if you're in that line just because i'm
a billionaire you're almost
disqualifying yourself you know what i
mean
for something serious exactly and jimmy
just as an aside says to my little
italian business partner this is maybe
1968 or 9. talking about tony
talking about tony women are having sex
with me
just to say they had sex with jimi
hendrix meaning i wasn't in the room
when he told her this story
he's talking to her because he can talk
to her as a human
and he's getting something off his chest
which is a hurt
and he says to her women are having sex
with me just to say they
had sex with jimi hendrix i'm 26
and a [ __ ] so my reaction is well
if there's a problem me and the boys can
help fill in the blanks we don't want
anyone's feelings to be hurt
meaning it's just stupidity
then i figured it out afterwards in the
years that went by
and women's libs started to happen that
this is insulting to jimmy very
insulting
meaning they just want a piece of him
they were stealing the clothes
when he says to me in this letter dear
couple
i need clothes expresso send whatever
you have
immediately and i'm thinking dude who
the hell you think you're talking to
this is mike i'm i just sent you
a whole wardrobe who that you know what
the hell's wrong with you
then mike figures out what's going on
what's going on is that the girls
are stealing the clothes that's number
one
that was one of the lessons in life for
me to learn like
you know everyone freaks out and they
say you know when we started to do the
outdoor art shows
susan writes a bio born here went to
school there
made clothes for and then it's you know
50 names or whatever big name drop
you ever meet cher did you meet jimi
hendrix i said oh no no we did it
through the internet you know
i didn't even have an internet then um
they couldn't believe that we ever met
him
you know and then i said yeah macho man
what was he like you know
all i'm saying to you is that people
put these entertainers on some
pedestal right some special place
these are humans you know and they're
not treated like humans the more the
the fame is
the less anyone could be one-on-one with
them back to
you know women are having sex with me
just to say they had sex with jimi
hendrix
you know you never thought of this in
your life
i never thought of it in my life but
once it goes down i'm going
you mean these 13 girls that are lined
up here they just want to have sex with
me because
they heard i made clothes for jimmy this
is why
well i'll try a few try a few you know
you understand the silliness of it
but it's a sad part of humanity that i
was forced to see
meaning i'm just a human like everybody
else you know and i got my favorite
actor or actresses or
singer or whatever you know that if you
you know i got to go make clothes for
whoever the thing is i'm i
mean why why did that make him sad
though why why would that make you sad
just because that's isn't that isn't
that just
the the nature of humans or the nature
of
sexual beings they they attract to the
the dominant alpha the the number one
the person who's going to protect them
the person who can
okay the answer is yes to what you're
saying but
this is just another person
with all the things that you have he may
have a different set of talents and a
different way of
operating a little bit but and obviously
a very different destiny so far
in your life anyway um but all i'm
saying to you is that
he knew how to communicate
on a record he knew how to communicate
with some fool that's making his clothes
in tampa
you know or saint petersburg at the time
um
so there's a beauty to just being
natural that's really what he was you
know where a lot of us
feel as though you know i can't be
natural i'm not sp i got to play this
part that's
what the culture is telling me is proper
or cool
or you know whatever right you know and
what he's saying just
go for it mike yeah you know do what you
do right
that's why he chose you so going back to
you were shipping all of these outfits
to him wherever he was it was
how many how many outfits were you
making for him in a month
like 50 you know no i would say
maybe 20 20 yeah and there was
and some of these women were just
stealing them from him and he had no
idea
no no he had an idea he knew they were
stealing them um
but the women would queue up
to be with him right they would you know
let's say we're in the hotel
we're doing clothes or we're hanging out
afterwards
people are coming to the door knocking
on the door i want an autograph
i want to meet jimmy whatever you know
and i got to say listen we're working
you know you do what you got to do but
you only got five minutes get it done
um and
some of the girls you let in
particularly one girl
that we let in that susan knew
the next morning she was there for five
minutes and left whatever the next
morning
she's there when we come meaning she had
spent the night she came
after we left late and then she was
there in the morning
this in tampa this is in tampa and i'm
not saying there's anything
wrong with this girl i'm just saying to
you
that this is
you if i say to you well here's 500
girls they all want to sleep
with you you go uh that's a little
overwhelming
can i have two or three
right right right i mean can we stretch
this out
over a week or how long do i have yeah
yeah but i mean
and i'm saying to you and you can hear
him say it in between
songs where he's saying he this is
dedicated to the girl in the seventh row
with the red underwear this is the girl
with the chrome uh knee pads you know
you'll hear it in between the songs
on yeah he's talking he's just thanking
people or talking to people or saying
whatever is on his mind at the moment
um i'd like to thank you for the last
three years
he
said three things to me about the end
one of which is i don't know how much
longer i'm going to be doing what i'm
doing